those nice next reject I'm good Eric do
you know what that is you know the
favors gray is healthy for you no one
has ever said that only things great
that you can eat and be happy for you is
uh I think seal meat what is that do you
know it's like a it's like some type of
like gray food or something
[Applause]
one day
[Applause]
thank you thank you thanks can you stand
this audience is on thin ice always good
to threaten the crowd if you come out
Eric that was very funny what you did to
McBrayer I've known that guy a long time
I always like to say he's a jerk show
business he's only one warriors
wonderful man but you know what comes
across in that clip which is so true of
your show you like to mess with the gas
we scorcher the guests a lot of these
shows are about making the guests
comfortable that's to torture yeah yes
we send rats out from underneath the
dust or [ __ ] cockroaches will come out
of the coffee mug or right tickle the
guests taint from underneath there she
do that what do you think Andy's busy
with that show yeah
[Laughter]
in there thanks for the idea
no but do guests know when they're
coming on the show like if I was coming
on your show I would think okay I know
they're gonna screw with me and do stuff
to me and be up for that but you have
guests that don't move
yes have no idea we had Abby Lee Miller
come in she's the dance mom you know
Dance Moms of one person this is gonna
go great yeah no she walked up to my
first ad and she was like is this a
cartoon or is it with real people
yeah then we were like yeah and so
you've done something like you've
probably gotten some publicist fired
because they tell their client you
should do the Eric Andre show the client
does it freaks out and then a publicist
gets fired
Lauren Conrad freaked out I Lauren
Conrad
really we probably got her publicist
fired yeah I I vomited on the desk
during the interview and pretended to I
pretended to but she thought it was real
and she walked out you know I'm curious
you did something to the exercise guru
Jillian Michaels yes and tell us what
you did we had a little person imitate
me and a little person imitate Jillian
and hide under the desk for the majority
of the interview and then I ripped the
dust cut in half and revealed these two
mini me mini Jillian's and continued the
interview and they would say whatever I
was saying
and many Jillian would say whatever
Jillian was saying it was hard to
concentrate I think we have a picture of
that now you can imagine her being
incredibly upset with how that was
that's so fantastic
Hannibal mini desk and she had no idea
they were hiding under there for like
half an hour
sweltering do you ever have a stupid
joke do you ever have a guest that comes
on and isn't prepared for this but then
they end up loving it they have a good
time I have slept with two of my guests
it's been great knowing yes well you
haven't asked who the two guests are it
was actually it was Larry King yeah been
there done yeah okay Judi Dench yeah
they're Dame Edna whatever
you